a new Guardian another stepping into the
spotlight and one degree from Kevin
Bacon keep watching to see how the
internet reacted to the first MCU
holiday special there's something for
everyone in the Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special from Easter eggs to a
casual confirmation of the collector's
fate after Avengers Infinity war in the
span of just 44 minutes James Gunn's
special dances between animation musical
numbers character introductions fight
scenes multiple Christmas parties and
everything in between but those ever
losing sight of the fact that it's very
much a touching holiday story at heart
in other words the holiday special is
one Wild Ride that's full of
Intergalactic holiday cheer just like
reviews have indicated now that fans
have the chance to see the special
themselves and make up their mind about
its quality it appears that the general
positive Buzz around the project is only
getting louder and louder viewers have
already started expressing their
opinions on Twitter and their comments
have highlighted several things about
the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special here's what Twitter had to say
about it one fan wrote this is my
favorite new holiday special another
analyzer viewing experience saying the
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
was so spectacular these guys have
already pulled me into the MCU and to
see something that's adorable and cute
eight years later is so special to me I
love them so much meanwhile some viewers
Drew attention to the special's
beautiful visuals and compared it
favorably to other MCU projects one user
one that allowed how was it that
Guardians of the Galaxy's holiday
special looks better than 70 of their
movies and as one of their greatest
projects yet others peppered their
praise for the specials General quality
with specific nods to newly appointed
Guardian cosmos space dog as voiced by
Maria bakalova and Kevin Bacon who plays
himself one put the user gushed it's so
nice having gunbackers writer and
director also Cosmo is so adorable I
can't wait to see more of her another
fan wrote of Cosmo new best Guardians
character well yet another user
suggested that every future holiday
special would benefit from an appearance
by bacon mantis hasn't had an easy
tenure in the MCU she served ego in
utter isolation for years and when she
met the Guardians she became a common
Target of jokes due to her naivety and
inexperience around people here however
she fully Rises to the front and center
of the story not only is her genuine
wish to make Star-Lord happy a front and
center of the holiday special but she
gets a cool buddy adventure with Drax
and is even revealed to be star-lord's
half-sister Twitter has taken notice of
mantis's important role in the special
and there has been much rejoicing a user
tweeted complementius mantis was a star
of the Guardians of the Galaxy Christmas
special everyone had their moments but
both mantis and Dave Batista's tracks
were on a different level perfect mix of
heart and humor another user agreed
writing mantis was heart of this show
she has proven why she is a guardian
being a prolific Twitter user James Gunn
himself took to the platform to join the
informal mantis Appreciation Society
before the special dropped and from the
looks of it he's very delighted that
people have embraced clementia's
character as the star of this particular
show gun tweeted I'm especially grateful
for all the Raves about Palm clementia's
performance as mantis this is mantis's
true debut as her full-fledged self in
the MCU out of the background and Out of
The Shadow of ego the Guardians of the
Galaxy holiday special features plenty
of scenes to get excited about but
Twitter seems to have taken an immediate
liking to one throwaway moment in
particular though neither nebula or
rocket feature particularly prominently
in the special the two former
adversaries share a moment that shows
just how far the relationship has come
clearly remembering that rocket has
taken a liking to The Winter Soldier's
cybernetic arm nebula has somehow
managed to acquire said arm off screen
and gives it to the visibly moved rocket
as a Christmas present this brief moment
of camaraderie has not gone unnoticed by
the twitarati
one fan tweeted he finally got Bucky's
arm another wrote rocket getting Bucky's
arm like he's wanted is one of the best
moments of phase 4. other users also
tweeted about the moment which might be
short but clearly resonates with viewers
the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special is available for streaming on
Disney Plus